ja hallo herr in bergheim christoph ich
habe zum wirklich brandaktuellen thema
atomkraftwerke in deutschland und auch
natürlich auf der ganzen welt habe ich
genau drei fragen und zwar meine erste
wäre ist atomstrom denn wirklich
billiger also akw es werden ja in
deutschland mit enorm hohen subventionen
vom staat gefördert diese subvention
müssen wir steuerzahler
letzten endes ja bezahlen
jetzt kommt auch noch diese neu
eingeführte brennelemente-steuer dazu
die ja natürlich auch wieder auf den
endkunden umgelagert wird
also ist letzten endes wirklich der
atomstrom billiger
als strom aus erneuerbaren energie der
atomstrom es billiger für die betreiber
die können den relativ günstig
abgeben
und produzieren
insgesamt ist der atomstrom
das sehe ich genauso wie sie
nicht billiger für die japaner
beispielsweise wird der atomstrom jetzt
ungeheuer teuer denn die müssen ja
jedenfalls als gesamte gesellschaft die
ganzen schäden und die jetzt dadurch
entstehen wir müssen ja finanzieren und
letztlich sind das kosten die der
atomstrom verursacht ich glaube nicht
dass das für die japaner jetzt
wirtschaftlich ist
atomkraftwerke zu betreiben um strom zu
erzeugen
dabei muss man wissen dass auf der
anderen seite der japanischen insel ein
anderer kraftwerksblock steht aus acht
kraftwerken nennt sich
kashiwazaki und diese anlagen stehen
auch schon seit jahren still
weil dort ein erdbeben kernkraftwerke
auch zerstört hat dort ist zwar kein
super gau entstanden aber die
kernkraftwerke wurden tatsächlich zum
teil so beschädigt dass sie eben bis
heute noch nicht wieder am netz sind das
geht auch andere kraftwerke dort die
schon lange still stehen alles das macht
den atomstrom enorm teuer
in
deutschland wäre es so wenn man dieses
ganze risiko was durch die unfälle ja
besteht versichern würde man muss ja
auch wenn man auto fährt da muss man ja
auch eine versicherung bezahlen weil man
ja andere die schäden erleiden in jedem
fall sicher sein müssen dass sie dann
auch die schäden bezahlt bekommen von
dem der auto fährt deswegen musste eine
versicherung haben das gleiche könnte
man vom kernkraftwerk fordern das ist
eigentlich etwas ganz natürliches und
das kernkraftwerk verpflichten wenn
irgendetwas passiert dann musst du
sicher sein dass die ganzen schäden
bezahlen kannst aber diese schäden die
sind so groß dass das keine versicherung
bezahlt keine versicherung man findet
keine versicherung die so etwas bezahlen
würde das heißt die
kernkraftwerksbetreiber ja stehen ohne
eine solche versicherung für solche
großen schäden da wir bezahlt es dann
zum schluss das ist der start und der
staat oder das sind die bürger über
steuern und wenn man jetzt ja
die konsequenz ziehen würde okay gibt
keine versicherung also gibt der staat
die versicherung aber der staat nimmt
damit nimmt zugleich von den betreibern
eine abgabe weil sie ja eigentlich über
den staat eine versicherung dann
finanzieren dann müssten die so viel
geld für diese versicherung bezahlen
dass der ganze strom völlig
unwirtschaftlich wäre er würde so teuer
werden der strom das sind keiner mehr
kaufen würde also daran sieht man auch
der atomstrom ist nicht billig bis teuer
was passiert denn wenn wirklich alle akw
es in deutschland abgeschaltet werden
würde wir haben zurzeit 17 oder 18 akw
in deutschland was würde passieren wenn
wir wirklich alle abschalten würden wir
uns in irgendeiner form abhängig machen
von einem anderen staat insofern dass
wir
strom aus frankreich zum beispiel oder
aus polen importieren würden weil es
weil hält der produzierte strom in
deutschland nicht mehr ausreichen würden
wir uns da irgendwie abhängig machen und
würde das auch noch eine kostenbelastung
darstellen dann die dritte frage
warum können denn jetzt auf einmal
wirklich sieben akw abgeschaltet werden
biblis b neckarwestheim 1 und so weiter
wenn vor ein paar monaten noch von der
aktuellen schwarz-gelben bundesregierung
die laufzeitverlängerung beschlossen
wurde
die
bundeskanzlerin und auch
die bundesregierung insgesamt hat
schon deutlich gemacht in ihren
gutachten bei der laufzeitverlängerung
dass deutschland möglicherweise etwas
strom importiert aber das führt nicht zu
einer importabhängigkeit deutschlands
von der energieversorgung
es waren im übrigen auch
bereits in den vergangenen jahren
häufiger fünf sechs reaktoren vom netz
weil sie repariert wurden oder eben
brennelementewechsel hatten uns war
zugleich und das mehrere monate lang
davon hat aber keiner was gemerkt die
stromversorgung die blieb stabil